I don't even know how you're still
standing first of all oh my god I
collapse I'm literally like you clap it
up and fell back that was a real thing
the week like we were I'm supposed to be
the pro and I'm sitting there like
listen I'm asking for managed Orton to
keep up and it's just it was a lot but
they stepped both of them separately
[Music]
I don't even know what to say first
whether it's the perfect score going in
or whether it was the fact that Len gave
you a standing ovation I mean like the
whole thing is just like sensory
overload for you guys do you know what
I'm saying
these days I think we'd go down in
dancing with the star history it's been
it's been crazy it was an incredible
night for so many reasons to be able to
have a night where it's been a really
tough week physically and only having
two days with Corvin that really
rehearsing building this piece and
whatnot and it culminating into a moment
where we saw three tens for both pieces
standing old from then I don't I can't
put it into words but I'm just so
grateful this is a good place to kind of
come into it with some serious momentum
I'm feeling extremely good about where
we are right now and I think it all goes
back to the fact that we have a great
relationship and we trust each other and
that's my plan on can you do it continue
doing I think that's all that we can do
do our best rely on each other and lean
on each other for the rest of this
competition as long as we stay in
[Music]